it's been a winter of both discontent
and widespread disruption in the NHS
staff from Porters to nurses physios to
ambulance workers angered by their wages
and conditions
and after nearly 20 000 canceled
operations and months of strikes a
breakthrough I'm delighted that the
government has reached agreement with
unions representing over a million NHS
workers on a fair and reasonable pay
settlement this agreement rightly
recognizes the Fantastic work that our
NHS workers like nurses midwives and
paramedics do whilst also being
affordable for the taxpayer the Royal
College of Nursing initially demanded a
pay increase of 19 this deal Falls some
way short of that with an initial
one-off payment of two percent in
addition to the pay review body's
recommendation of at least a four
percent salary increase there will also
be a five percent increase in wages next
year while the lowest paid workers will
receive a 10.4 bump bringing them in
line with the national living wage one
of the key outstanding questions though
is where this money comes from there was
no part announced in the budget the
health secretary has been clear that it
won't come from patient funding but if
it is to be fine from somewhere else in
the NHS budget well then what has to be
cut to pay for it
unions admit the offer is lower than
initial expectations now they must
convince their members to vote for it
health workers can now decide
Queen taking further strike action and
picking up an offer I know that you know
me and other trade unions work together
to uh to engage with the government and
press for as much money as we could it
won't be straightforward Bert is an
oncology nurse and says the offer isn't
enough to make up for the increase in
pressure and decrease in conditions
personally I would say say no to this
offer because I don't think it's it's up
it's an offer that come towards the
challenges that we have within the NHS
and I'm I'm ready to step up and strike
again
tens of thousands of NHS workers voted
to strike for better pay no they must
decide if the offer is good enough
but with Junior doctors still to start
their own negotiations with the
government the threat of yet more
walkouts hasn't gone away Matthew
Thompson Sky News